vini brand is here once again because he
can't keep his name out of the headlines
I have any I texted yesterday maybe even
wouldn't want to call in today but
Vinnie legitimately on the phone it's
your hearing at times there's a little
dicey so yeah I definitely it's better
you come yeah when I walked up to the
security desk and he's like you again
yeah this pretend there where is he
coming from
well I like that you're figuring out
ways to continuously get back in here
you know whether it means getting comics
to leave the club whatever you have to
do stay in the headlines and keep us
talking yeah you know I don't want to be
in the headlines no no no this is a
Monday night show Pete was doing yeah
was a Monday night show Davidson
yeah Pete Davidson who listen I'm gonna
say right up front
I love Pete Davidson I don't want to be
for Pete Davidson and I've never
disrespected that guy ever I heard you
did once on Monday that is the word yeah
well that's that's aparts pissing me off
is that first of all they asked me to go
up on stage who today his security team
okay talk to Pete beforehand did he ask
you anything I talked to people in the
greenroom for two minutes
and Pete's green room is not a green
room I'm gonna hang out it sure okay so
I went in it was all good hug he goes
hey the club beautifies to Pete thank
you very much for coming in yeah man
yeah good good I asked if you'd seen the
show room yet
which he did not and I go listen you're
gonna love it in there and I said to
Pete who do you want me to bring it
first he had you know great comics with
him it does it bring him dark gains
first I said great I said okay who else
was with him Derek Ricky it was dark
Gaines Ricky people that's what I tell
you and the guys missing out his name
I'm blanking Colin Quinn yeah Norm
Macdonald no he's on now oh my god
Robert Downey jr. I never had Jim Breuer
no Tina Fey no it was John Belushi the
point is Amy Poehler
what was it I want to know gainin Chris
right okay Chris right okay all right
and I apologize because Ricky Velez it's
Chris red and it's dark gains in common
and the and they're there Pete Davidson
brings them yeah he brought those guys
that night and and I literally said who
am i bringing him first it's a dark
games and then I left the greenroom I
said hi to everybody you guys have a
great time tonight
they're all eating all having fun I walk
outside that's it now during the day I
had talked to his security team and his
chief of security wasn't gonna be there
that night he had another guy doing the
job how big is a security team
it's that night he had two guys okay all
right and we had three guys we hired
three guys to make sure this thing ran
right right no phones no phones and they
were very specific what they wanted was
more than just the standard no phone
policy they wanted no phones on the
table no phones and hands phones
couldn't be visible that's fair
because they said it is fair they say
listen people will try and record the
audio sure and we don't want that sure
that makes sense right so we had signs
everywhere signs a discuss to put up and
I said to Pete I'm gonna go up on stage
I'm gonna lay down the law and get your
guy on right away cuz great I leave the
green room I'm out front during the day
the security guy said listen please tell
everybody no calling out and if they
calling out Peter handle out as a comic
himself but if they yell out ariana
grande or Kate Beckett saw they're gonna
remove from the club immediately so I
thought okay that makes sense makes
total sense
it's always saying is he's asking you
just cuz somebody yells out don't
necessarily remove them immediately but
if they yell that out immediate immunity
exactly is it possible you
misinterpreted that as wanting it
announced and the security guy was just
saying that to you like look if this
happens during the day that conversation
I had I could have potentially yeah but
the way this played out is very specific
ax which it which is what pissed me off
so right before I'm gonna go onstage and
I'm talking they're really getting ready
to intro me the security guys with me he
came out and he said you know you're
bringing up Derek I said what do you
want for credits and he said you know do
the glass Sergey and the reason it's
important is because the guy said say
that I said yeah I was kidding around
ago I can't do that you know Tracy gets
mad when I do that and the guy went to
run back and Derek something else and I
said no no I'm only kidding you I mean
of course I'm going to do
credits and then I said to him okay I'm
gonna tell them no cellphones you can't
have a phone on the table Kevin in your
hands I'm gonna tell them no calling out
and I'm gonna specifically say no
yelling out ariana grande or Kate
Beckinsale or you will be removed
immediately it's a one and done
situation and that dude looked at me and
said yes perfect say that exactly okay
and I went up on stage I was on stage
for four minutes and 50 seconds my
security tape shows it it takes four
minutes to do these announcements
because I'm telling people listen if you
bring your cell phone out and put it on
the table we're gonna ask you to leave
the room they also told me during the
day that if someone gets a phone call
just ask him to please leave the room
and go to our lobby and make the call so
it's a very specific set of
announcements right I made no joke
anyway this is what happens when too
many people get involved the guy and
PTIN him just don't talk it's so much
more complicated this it really is but
when you're doing announcements you got
to do them in a way that's not so like a
disciplinarian right are you doing them
in a jovial way I did these
announcements with almost no inflection
because it's 9:45 on a Monday night it's
already late this was the second trying
to get the sheets up doing one show so I
am very aware that on a Monday night an
audience can get tired so I want to move
it along I say okay I know what I'm
doing I've been doing this for 30 years
all right I don't need to go on you know
Pete tried to say I went up into time
and he asked me not to listen Pete I
love you
you call me but that didn't happen and
if if Pete had not gone on Instagram
this would have none of this would have
been known because I wouldn't have gone
public with us and I did my job so good
there's no videotape of me because the
first thing I was looking everywhere for
it there wasn't there right there's no
video of you Sam Harry stress factory
doing this yeah because I did my job
right yeah and I do my job very well and
comedians if Pete didn't say I
disrespected him if Pete just said hey
something went wrong I wouldn't have
done anything Pete called me out by name
listen my reputation in this business is
all I have I don't have any credits this
is my biggest credit right now let me
let me play I actually have the audio
just to bring people up to speed so this
is
so obviously Pete Davidson is supposed
to get on stage of the stress bag oh you
silly I want this one before that before
do you say you you make this
announcement how do you say don't call
it all right are you [ __ ] do the sound
like you're making I'll carry just you
just saying you'll be asked to leave
immediately yeah and let me tell you
like I'm really self-aware so I said to
my manager Marc who's been with me for
20 years
I said Marc tell me if I [ __ ] up if I
did it in a joking way please tell me
because I need to know that Marcus Vinny
you didn't do anything they didn't ask
you to do because you did it exactly the
way they're not told so when okay that
happened how do you find out he's
leaving because you're on stage yeah and
then what did you bring on Derrick I
brought our Derrick went up when I
walked off the security guys you know
you've been to the room I stepped off
stage for that little door yeah the
green rooms to the left I didn't go to
the green room I said to the security
guy just cocky I said that's how you
control crowd and I walked into the
lobby and the guy said to me yeah good
job okay that's what he didn't say
not okay now now listen I want to send
some fatica Lee I don't want any I would
love it if Pete Davidson reached out and
said hey Vinny let's put this behind
this I would shut up in real time okay
please let Pete do that so in any event
I'm out front now talking but you know
as long as you've been doing this isn't
there any part of you that goes like wow
it's one thing to say don't yell out you
know what I mean obviously that's
something you should say but if I say
don't yell out and specifically don't
say these two things when you say don't
say these two things isn't that kind of
like dangling the carrot like hey this
is the really bad stuff okay first of
all I can see why you're saying that
yeah but I'm talking about 30 seconds
before I'm walking on stage if that guy
said to me
no no just say don't yell out none of
this happens and there have been times
there's certain comments I've worked
with where they want a two-man show
and I know they're a certain way I just
say you know what I'm not even gonna do
the announcements if someone makes a
phone call he'll have to deal with that
okay
I like P and respect P and I wanted that
night to be perfect this is a brand new
Club nine years in the making a lot of
my wife's and eyes time money and energy
300 people coming out of Monday night
you think you think even a little bit of
me said hey let me [ __ ] this up so yeah
right yeah III don't think you were
going out of your way to [ __ ] with them
no that's the last thing you're gonna do
and you have you know a guy as hot as
Pete you know like everyone's talking
about Pete Davidson and he's funny and
happened your club will send you're
gonna [ __ ] with him on purpose it
doesn't make sense oh my god this is
this is the thing if you go through
anything I've ever done like what to
face Kathy Griffin anything with Lois
I'm never on stage dishing on comics
never okay
I shot myself and my family I don't
really do that ever so to say I'm
disrespecting comedians it was very very
troubling to me so you okay so that you
walk off you go out into the lobby it
Derek Gaines goes on when do you find
out there's a problem it's about five
minutes or six minutes Derek's onstage
and he's doing very well
Derek's a funny guy she is and tonight's
gonna be amazing because they're not
gonna yell out and just to finish that
point Sam
the odds of someone yelling at her
during that show if I don't make the
announcement are probably a hundred
percent
it's Monday night they're drinking
there's always a jackass somewhere with
these big celebrities that wants to do
it so when you up front say this isn't a
joke we don't want to hear that I said
if you yeah I have these two things
specifically you will be removed from
the club it's a one and done situate
although personally I think the better
announcement and maybe this is the
security guy if he's if he's not as
every day guy sometimes security guys
you know they're like ex cops they're
like very fact oriented official [ __ ]
guys just tell them this Telma but he'd
say one yet if you heckle once you're
out that would have covered that and
then anything they yelled you could have
either thrown them out or not oh yeah
and in hindsight I wish I didn't go
onstage in hindsight I said hey you know
what if someone yells out that person
will get thrown
but in fairness to the people that came
out I think you should tell him hey
listen this is the ground rules if you
do this you're going out of the room
right so you're not shocked when they I
thought you're all having a good time
you know what if they don't know that
they can't yell out during a show then
they deserve to be shocked on the way
home I think it's fair to make one
announcement you yell out it's a one and
done policy you're [ __ ] gone but I
don't think you should have to tell them
specifically because I think as adults
if they don't know that that's a great
lesson to learn yeah [ __ ] yelled out
some one thing if you talking during a
movie and you got thrown out you didn't
tell me I couldn't be on my the one
universal rule of comedy yeah okay but
you know what let's face facts he is a
celebrity he's he's a comic but he's at
another level and his his relationships
have been highly publicized okay so this
is this and it made London news say I
got a friend of mine in London that
sends me a text message hey they're
beating you up in the London press I'm
like oh my god now I've got credits in
London - yes London Connecticut I mean
you're talking about guys a celebrity
and when you get to that yes your level
of celebrity you wouldn't understand
this Jim of course not I was like the
stress factory people take that money
okay that's why and they're not
necessarily comedy fans either like
they're not used to this the rules of
they are idiots when it comes to seeing
stand-up comedy because they don't see
stand-up comedy they see they're going
to see a celebrity they are and and
listen if I wasn't so emotionally
involved in making the club great and
making comedians experience great if
Pete had not gone on Instagram you would
never have heard the story so so Derrick
is on stage Derrick's on stage for five
minutes
right and that same security guy comes
up and says hey man he's leaving you
need you know the joint you know there's
no show and they're packing up all the
merch that I got what are you talking
about and he cuz he's upset that you
said Arianna Grande and I said to him
because it was the same guy said dude
you told me to say that because man you
better go talk to Pete he's like I'm out
of this right now
no he didn't no he didn't there were two
security guys there huh there was there
was a guy that told me that
there was a heavier guy nice guy yeah
and they both heard me say it they both
heard me say this is the announcement so
now I go out in the in the alleyway he's
getting in the car to Pete I go what's
going on cuz man you humiliated me I got
Pete I would never disrespect you I love
you I've known you for a long time I
didn't that guy told me to say exactly
what I said
and now the guy goes who inside did not
say to me hey Vinnie I didn't say that
says oh I didn't say that I could dude
you did it was it was four minutes ago
you said that and endless and this is I
get it the guys trying to keep his good
yeah it's tough when all the sudden when
Pete's right there if you said that to
the club owner and the [ __ ] celebrity
is pissed you're like oh [ __ ] yeah which
one of my oh yeah and what he did is
[ __ ] call me a liar and he stepped
toward mister dude don't hit me now the
other guy was there I said oh you really
took a stance not for anything but I'm
out there with pizza guys I don't have a
lot of my guys there yeah yeah and
there's a lot of them and the other
security guys there I said guy you can't
let this go down this way you tell them
what happened and he goes I don't want
to get involved okay which is a really
really in my opinion that's that telling
thing to say I don't want to get
involved says hey I can't I'm not gonna
say it didn't happen because I know it
did and I'm not gonna corroborate it cuz
I'm not gonna get in trouble and I then
I literally I begged Pete there now if
someone said in one of these news
stories that I was out there screaming
and cursing and getting violent with
Pete yeah that's what everybody would do
you will go out and get violent and try
and scare them back onstage okay none of
it makes sense so pizza in the car I
said Pete please don't do this it's a
brand new Club we've been friends
forever I love you I would never ever
hurt you any he just looked at me I said
there's three of your fans in there and
I said to the driver all right said the
penis this guy tells you the truth where
you go to the show because yeah
so again evidence of Pete's a pretty
good guy and that's a guy tell him he
wouldn't say a word he didn't say yes No
he's lost his bluster he's not gonna hit
me anymore
because I hope you learned your lesson
they drive away and I'm like yeah I'm
sorry I love Pete they had a lot of
respect for Pete I wish him well I
really wish you would reach out for me
because I don't I texted to see if he'll
call I don't even know if he got the if
he's up at this hour
listen there are people on my facebook
saying you know pizza dick and bye bye
bye I was there a pizza [ __ ]
listen don't don't do that either okay
there are people saying I had one girl
my Instagram going you were
unprofessional you disrespect the beat I
wrote back hey what what's your ticket
name let me look yeah then I look up she
lives in California
okay the girl's not there so that's the
thing now it takes on this other life
where all the trolls come out and people
or people who just don't know what
happened and they just react to a story
yeah they read a headline yeah they do
and let's here's what Pete said oh yes
Instagram yeah he recorded this
Instagram in the car as after you had
had that conversation so when Derek is
onstage the balls all this is happening
well this Instagram Derek point in the
car with him so so the stage is empty oh
yeah they're all that wait how did
everybody for this okay how did
everybody find out that it was done so I
guess the guys on the girl I don't know
how Derek got notified on stage because
when I when when they came and got me I
went out and talked to me in the
alleyway Derek was already offstage and
they're all getting in the car so they
just literally so they're offstage
weren't you gonna who's bringing the
next guy on I wasn't going back on Derek
was supposed to bring on Ricky villa and
Ricky was gonna bring on Chris Wragge
Yeah right so gonna tag-team the show so
I'm done I'm five minutes onstage I'm
done for the night now my whole job is
gonna be make sure the rest of this
night goes well make sure no one
violates the policy that's my homeless
count the money the funny thing about
this uh you know it's it's a door deal
yeah and it's not favorable to me I'm
not gonna cap a lot of money push and
that's the other thing I you know you're
hurting a brand new club you still have
a career here on Saturday Night Live
you're you're a big star okay this is my
livelihood and my relationship with
comedians is important so this is not
you're literally gonna maybe take
me apart and there's a guy in Instagram
we gotta close this club down okay
people just yeah don't worry about
social media people but so so the stage
is empty as all this is going down in
the alleyway right now I go back in
because they drove away there's nothing
I deserve that's it and I said to mark
get ready I'll do the show we have a
host their houses Sam hunter who was he
on stage at this point no Sam hunter he
stays empty stage is empty okay and I'm
gonna say something about this guys Sam
hunter is 2-year comic and I'll tell you
something this guy's a rock star in my
opinion because here's what happens I go
back up on stage and I say to people I
was super respectful about Pete I say
listen guys I have a terrible
announcement to make
Pete got offended there was a
miscommunication I you know he left and
we don't know how what was the first
time extreme Derek Ames
we don't know how Derek got offstage I
still don't know that I don't know that
answer and so what happens is I went up
on stage I said listen if you stay we're
obviously gonna refund all your money
and I will do a show for you and I'll be
very very funny give me two minutes I'm
gonna put an opening act here Sam hunter
who is Sasser room and it's literally
operating this night yep as a you know
door person I look the room sedges Sam
you're doing a set get ready and we
brought him up 30 seconds later to a
pissed-off crowd and it killed and if
Sam hunter if you're listening I I
[ __ ] love you and I hope you become a
big star and I'm gonna try and help that
happen ever used to say that about Pete
David said sure now look what happened
yeah you're on stay as salmon you are
going onstage this is what Pete is
saying on his Instagram video hey guys
in Connecticut I'm sorry that we had to
leave the show before I got to go on
owner of any brand disrespected me and
did something that I told them not to do
and I can't ever everybody who got
tickets to that show I am doing a free
show for you guys will figure out where
it's gonna be in the next week and you
know all get it all sorted out sorry
again this is not your home so that's
what sticks in your craw he specifically
says that you Vinnie brain he did and
and listen again there's no evidence of
anything there was no joke that's first
of all it's just not true I didn't do a
joke about it and so then what happened
after that is I was on stage and I'm
just doing my set inglis and it's a hard
set to do I've had to do this a couple
of times when things have gone wrong you
have ran and yeah as you work tonight on
site because your daughter called me
then I'd Geraldo died because now he was
a stress factory yeah did you do the set
that night to which oh that was you okay
I had to it was something you said they
killed Geraldo yes was that what
happened yes he said I'd like to book
you again
I can't do it no but that was it that
happened right and that was another
emotionally charged night the audience
didn't know at that point but they just
do something was wrong yeah I was in the
back eating a salad and they said hey
you gotta go to the hotel they can't
wake Durazo up I ran down ran back to
the club Melvin George was on stage and
and I I had to go up and headline that
show which was a really difficult choke
is in my head Greg and I were friends
that did you know he was dead at that
point or did you or did you not use knew
something was very bad the guide the
hotel said listen hearing coming tonight
and hearing coming tomorrow
and so I know it was bad so you know
then I had to go up and do the show and
I killed anyway so now on this show what
I'm doing in in for Pete's show
I'm just doing my stuff and I'm trying
to move through it have a good set and
some of his hey man he's on Instagram
trashing you live I saw that clip
someone heckled I should have been
removed huh I'm sorry well by then by
then everybody had realized there's a
free-for-all because that clip exists
somebody taped that and I said I said
play it right I wish I didn't do could
it pissed me off and then I addressed it
and said and I said I'm say JP because
when people's going through his trouble
last year the last number I have
repeated probably not as a number but I
texted him your guy he if you need
someone just to talk to you what number
did he give you it was for one one no
people used to come in the club when he
wasn't known he would hang out with his
mother his mother and I talked for hours
Pete used to jokingly call me hey Dad
you know and it was a relationship so
you're saying you were like a father to
Pete Davidson you know I listen I don't
think I was because but Pete would say
that and his mother would talk to me and
he would tease his mother and go mom
leave him alone he's married and it
would make a joke about it and but when
I tell you I talked to Pete mom is not
only were you like a father to Pete
Davidson he wanted you to have sex with
his mom
oh jeez Sam don't go I'm just trying to
make sure that it's all funded Danny was
trying to angle it yeah he was and he
was trying to angle it anyway I put the
kid on yeah wonderful three being woman
like yeah come here let me let me help
you out with this I respect pnath mother
none of that is true and so you know
anyway that's when I went on stage and
said hey Pete you know that's not true
you know I didn't do that and I would
never do that
and I'll say Anglet some Pete's looking
for somewhere to do the show in
Connecticut listen we had a problem with
Margaret Cho a couple years ago that's
right and she came back right that was a
stress Factory yep she came back and we
put it all the bed and it was great
which is Seinfeld go on yes yeah he
killed and the thing is I would do the
same thing repeat because you want to
Seinfeld to your club I don't blame you
let Jerry I still like Pete yeah it's
one of those things where he thought
like all right Vinnie knows not to do
this you have a conversation with the
security guy that he doesn't know right
and then you want to do that he's in
back home what the [ __ ] why is he doing
this yes and the security guard is not
coming in and going no I told him look
make sure you mentioned this so as far
as he knows you just did that like why
the [ __ ] would you do it Yeah right
it just not something it isn't Wow I
mean look of all the things especially
in a brand new club where it's a Monday
night I'm thrilled were sold out all I
wanted was to get make it easy I had
just done seven nights of working around
going in on that Monday night at 9:45 so
I'm driving two hours to get there doing
the show two hours home I didn't want
anything to go wrong how are you feeling
on that drive home two hours drive home
after all this had happened are you
feeling angry are you feeling sad upset
frustrated how are you feeling it's not
it's gonna sound like I'm a bit of it's
like you lost your it was it was
saddening yeah because it I know the
impact and I know that when he does he's
at 2.4 million followers I've got 5,200
that's good yeah that seemed a little
high it's I mean look I'm not trying to
sound like like I'm being bullied but
God Almighty how do I even respond it
it's not believed but you know he's
taking a he's taking a beating like you
know he's [ __ ] dating Ariana Grande
Pete yeah yeah and then he [ __ ] they
break up and he gets murdered online
like he's [ __ ] so he's probably just
sensitive to it and then he thinks like
oh my god my friend is [ __ ] with me
yeah and you know and Pete entered into
this world where everything that he does
now is news as you know everything that
Pete does is headline news he became
this giant celebrity because of you know
the people that he was dating and I
guess he's become very very protective
about how that stuff gets out because
people are such constant right like
people weren't just reporting on it he
was getting brutalized by her fans and
then people were just just smashing him
and he's probably the grande I would say
think about what you just said people
are just such jackasses right so isn't
that why the announcements important
isn't that why you say some no I I would
never say specifically I would say no
heckling but when you tell people now
don't yell Blue Devil but I didn't say
it like that
but I mean just through the idea of
telling them immediately puts it in
their heads like you said they're drunks
there is a citation
yeah if but I think if you say it's a
zero-tolerance policy any heckling and
you're out people kind of know any
heckling kinda but you know either way
then you just throw them out but again
he's at a celebrity level and kind of
know listen if I did there over again
obviously I wouldn't say it right and if
the guy didn't tell me right before I
walked onstage I wouldn't have said it
look hindsight is the key it's a it's a
pretty it's a pretty direct thing yes
perfect say that exactly I believe you
pretty on you know I just think it was a
mistake by the security guy to to walk
because you never want to say
specifically but don't yell this because
hearing a guy who know it no he probably
didn't really nicely security idly on
his he's probably just thinking this is
the right thing to do this way and to be
no hassles they won't bug Pete I don't
have to throw anybody out with with the
owner is not a master of human
psychology because it's always whenever
you're going through other people yeah
there's always a miscommunication
whether it's a publicist security guy
because everyone thinks they have
everyone else's [ __ ] interests oh I
know what the person wants I mean while
people I would have said no no no don't
say that would because I've had guys say
they would like do you want this set no
let me tell you this and it happened to
the club in New Brunswick and it was a
major issue we had a guy in the back and
he used his security guy to order food
okay security guy just go through a
waitress and orders food we're in the
middle of a Russian two sold-out show so
you know that's one of my shows Kenny
comes up to me he goes mr. Norton's food
is not and I'm like well who'd you order
it with he goes some waitress I go what
did you tell the waitress it was from
mr. Norton because I didn't think that
was necessary I thought it was
understood I was joking
oh yeah that can happen where one person
thinks you want this but you actually
want that and like your Pete said to you
don't hey look man don't don't mention
that and then you did it then I'd say
all right he has a legit [ __ ] yeah
first off but the middleman also you
know whether it's the security guard a
publicist whoever it is that's doing the
talking for you so often they want to
have the conversation without the
celebrity that they're representing
actually having to said anything because
they want it to go right and go oh you
didn't even have to say anything I
telling you during the day the chief
security guy and I had a conversation
and it was great if that guy was there
that night I assure you he would've said
no no don't do that he would have known
then he was second in command or
whatever how you want to call him
Angliss he's a nice guy he shouldn't
lose a job either this stuff happens if
if I had made a joke you can't find it
you can't find an ariana grande joke I
don't know her I wouldn't do that joke
cuz I respect artists in general I don't
do it you wouldn't do it right before
you bought the guy on doesn't make sense
I don't do it period one more Jim and
Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM f
[Music]